Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today we'll be racing against
my bowels because I have about 15
minutes until I have explosive diarrhea.
So, let's get this video underway. Uh,
today I will be doing the low-level
design of an order book. Uh, if you
don't know what an order book is, I'm
going to teach you. And on the event
that this happens to turn you into a
Jordan Belffort type, please do send
some help my way. I'll greatly
appreciate it. And for legal reasons,
that was a joke. Okay, let's get into
this. All righty. So let's go over what
a limit order book is. Uh we'll go over
some design decisions that we might make
when implementing this. Uh it is more of
an algorithmic problem maybe more than
anything, but I don't really think there
are too many good videos actually
covering how to do kind of the class
design that you would want for an order
book. And so I'm going to try and go
into that and uh explore it with a
little bit of depth. Okay. So what is a
limit order book? Well, let's imagine
that we're only considering one stock
for now because in reality there's going
to be different order books for every
single stock. But the general gist of
this is that an order book basically
keeps track of all the open orders. When
you're trying to buy or sell a stock,
sometimes there's not somebody else who
wants to buy or sell that stock and take
the other side of the trade. Uh when
that happens, your basically unfilled
order goes into the order book. And
there are two sides of the order book.
There's the ask side and the bid side.
The ask side basically represents all of
the open selling orders. Meaning, let's
say I had 100 shares of an Apple stock
and I wanted to sell them. That would go
in the ask side of the order book until
that half of the order was filled. And
then same with bidding. Let's say I
wanted to buy 50 shares of Google. Well,
then that would go in basically the bid
side of the book until someone else
basically went ahead and sold me 50
shares. So like I've said on the slide
here, we have basically the prices and
the corresponding volumes which is just
the number of shares that people who
have not yet had their order filled want
to buy and sell of a stock. And there
are a few rules to this order book
basically for you know when new
potential trades are coming in how they
would actually go ahead and get filled.
So, as you can see, we have our
basically bid and ask side of the book.
And a trade is going to be made if the
highest bid is greater than or equal to
the lowest ask, meaning that the spread
has been crossed. So, the spread is
basically the term for the difference
between the lowest ask and the highest
bid. And so, when they cross, it means
that there's someone who's actually
willing to pay uh greater than or equal
to the amount that someone is willing to
sell at. And so a trade is going to be
initiated and that volume is going to be
removed from the order book. Now what if
it's the case that one side was in the
order book already and the other side
basically initiates the trade. Well, the
price that that order is going to uh
basically happen at is the price of the
order that was already in the book. So
keep that in mind. That's one rule we
have to talk about. Um, another one is
actually going to be the fact that
basically, um, if orders are all going
to be, you know, basically if an order
comes in that crosses the spread and
there are multiple orders on the other
side or there are multiple basically
open orders on the other side that could
fail an order with that, you're going to
ultimately uh perform the trade with the
open order that came in first. So, we're
going to be doing those in chronological
order. it implies we'll have to be using
some sort of Q or something along those
lines down the line based on a
timestamp. Okay, so let's move onwards.
You can read the slide for you know more
details about the rules but I hope that
explains things. Okay, so let's think
about our order book interface. So let's
we'll we'll first do a basic order book
and then uh towards the end of the video
I'll explain some possible expansions to
the problem and touch upon those a
little bit. But this is going to be our
main functionality that we care about
the most. So the interface that I wanted
to define and the reason I'm doing this
as an interface is because there are
multiple possible implementations of our
order book is going to have three main
methods. We have one to place an order
and so placing an order is basically
going to do the following. It's going to
try and fill that order meaning it's
going to try and find an open order in
the order book that can be combined with
it to make a trade. or if you can't make
a series of trades due to that order
that was just placed, then you're going
to go ahead and place that in the order
book and maybe down the line that trade
will actually go down. Um, we also have
this option to cancel an order. Like I
said, sometimes orders are going to be
placed but not actually filled, and
they'll go in the open order book.
Cancelelling that order will make sure
that you won't actually be able to fill
that order in the future if it has yet
to be filled. If it has been filled,
that's just a no op. And then finally,
we also want to be able to get the
volume at a price point for a given side
of the trade. So let's say I want to see
all right, how many people are currently
selling the stock Apple for $50 or not
how many people, but rather how many
shares are being sold at the price of
$50. We could then go ahead and easily
get this uh by calling our get volume at
price method. Okay, so let's also uh
obviously we need to basically
encapsulate the state of an actual
order. Um, and so I went ahead and
listed out some fields that would be
useful in something like an order class.
Um, having an order class is useful for
a variety of reasons. Technically, the
state isn't going to be changing too
much. So, it's possible that we don't
need a class. We could maybe use some
different data structure like a
dictionary to represent this, but at the
end of the day, being able to kind of
abstract this away in a class is good
for, you know, putting it in other data
structures. For example, something like
a Q or a linked list or a heap or
anything along those lines. It's nice to
have kind of a node structure that we
can abstract an order away with. So,
we're going to have an order ID. We're
going to have a time stamp. We're going
to have a side that is part of our buy
or sell enum. So, I'm just going to
assume side is buy or sell. Uh we're
also going to have a price, which is
going to be a double or a float. Uh we
will have a volume, which is the number
of shares that's either being, you know,
sold or bought. And then also a client
name. That's just going to be useful for
when we're actually printing out a trade
that has executed. And again, you know,
obviously I've made these all private.
So I'm assuming that in an actual class
you would have public getters and
setters uh just for the purposes of, you
know, kind of making sure that you can't
actually access the instance variables
of this class.
Okay, so let's go ahead and think about
some sort of data structures for our
limit order book because this is
ultimately going to be a pretty complex
problem and there's not only one way
that you can do this, but I'm going to
touch upon one possible implementation.
And if you guys have any other ideas in
the comments, feel free to go ahead and
comment those. I'd be interested to see
what you guys can come up with as well.
But as far as I'm aware, this is one of
the more common ways of implementing it.
So basically, we know when an order
comes in, let's imagine that we're
submitting a buy order, right? So I want
to buy 50 shares of Google. The first
thing that we're going to do is go ahead
and look at the lowest price of the sell
side of the limit book, right? Because I
want to see what people are willing to
sell Google for. If I'm willing to buy
Google shares at a price that's greater
than or equal to that lowest sell price,
then we're going to execute a trade. And
if I wasn't able to buy all the shares
that I wanted, I'm going to keep
checking the sell limit order book in
order of the lowest prices to see if I
can make even more trades. So,
obviously, we're going to have some sort
of while loop in our logic. And keep in
mind as well that I basically just told
you guys the way that I'm looking at uh
the limit order book in terms of who I'm
going to actually execute my trade with
is in terms of the price point. Right? I
am prioritizing uh open orders that have
the lowest price. So what would be
really good for this would be a priority
queue which is often implemented by a
min heap. uh so it would be really
useful to kind of represent the sell
side of the order book with a min heap
so that that way I can quickly see
what's the lowest price that I can buy
shares at and similarly uh you can also
implement the buy side of the order book
with a max heap so that you can quickly
see what is the highest price that
someone's willing to buy shares of a
stock at. And so now we basically have
this structure of two heaps. We have a
min heap for our sell side. We have a
max heap for our buy side. And in
addition, uh, it actually gets a little
bit more complicated. But keep in mind,
and sorry there's a typo on the slide. I
said n login inserts and pops. It's
actually login where n is the number of
nodes in the heap. But what actually are
our nodes in the heap? It's not actually
going to be so simple as to just say
that, hey, we have just a bunch of order
nodes in our heaps, right? because we
actually said to ourselves, hey, we know
that um we basically have all these
orders, but there can be many orders at
the same price point, right? I might
want to buy 50 shares of Apple, and
then, you know, my friend also might
want to buy 50 shares of Apple. And so,
we would go in the heap in the same
place. But I've already said that, you
know, if there are two people willing to
buy shares at the same price, the one
who gets priority is the one that
actually submitted their order earlier,
meaning they have an earlier time stamp.
So what we could actually do, we have a
couple options here. Uh, one option is
to just go ahead and make our heaps
based on both the price and the time
stamp, but it is actually a little bit
algorithmically faster if we were to use
a queue. The reasoning for this being
that now we're not adding a bunch of
extra nodes to our heap, which uh goes
around in kind of logarithmic time, but
rather we can have um basically a heap
of Q's where the Q's are representing
just one price level for an open order.
And then within those cues we have
actually the basically the order nodes
themselves uh in the order that they
were submitted. Right? So it means that
pulling from the beginning of the queue
is going to show you the earliest order
and then we're going to get the things
that we want. Right? So now we finally
satisfied our requirement of being able
to look through those heaps in the
proper order and also if there's a
tiebreaker we can settle it using that
time stamp field.
Okay. So now we have basically these two
heaps right? Right? We have our max heap
and our min heap. And each of those
heaps is made up of a bunch of different
cues and those cues contain orders.
Right? So this is already getting pretty
complicated and I understand that and I
empathize with you there, but it's only
getting worse because we mentioned that
we need volume. So volume is basically
saying what is the open amount of shares
that uh people either want to buy or
want to sell at a given price. And so
right now we know that all of the orders
at a given price are represented by
basically being part of a que. And
that's all good and well. However, uh
it's not very efficient time-wise. And
we know that we want to make our
algorithmic complexity as low as
possible during the course of this
problem because in an actual market
exchange or a stock exchange, it's super
important to make things super fast or
else they're going to be inefficiencies
that people can take advantage of. So we
want our volume to basically be running
as fast as possible. And right now our
volume or at least calculating it would
be an O of N. The reason for this being
that we have to iterate through a Q at a
given price point and add up the sums of
the number of shares that each order
wants. So instead what we can actually
do is as opposed to um kind of lazily
figuring out what the volume is, we can
actually premputee it and we can do this
by maintaining a hashmap. So the hashmap
is going to basically take in a tupil as
a key where the tupil is both the price
that we care about and also the side.
So, buying or selling. And every single
time that we add an order to our limit
order book, we can go ahead and
increment the volume available for that
order's price inside in the hashmap. And
if we were to ever remove an order from
the limit order book because either it
was filled or it was canceled, we can go
ahead and remove the corresponding
volume amount in our hashmap. So, that's
just an extra thing to keep keep up
with. Okay.
Next, we have cancellations.
cancellations is probably where this
problem gets, I would say, the most
challenging in terms of actually going
ahead and thinking through the
trade-offs that we need to make. And
there are a couple of possible ways that
we can cancel an order. We can kind of
actively do it or we can lazily do it.
So the active way that we can do this is
um we basically go ahead and take the
node representing an order and we simply
remove it from the queue that it's a
part of and effectively remove it from
the heap. So we're now no longer ever
going to consider it for filling future
orders. So, uh, this is really good in
the sense that, um, it means that there
are going to potentially be fewer things
in the heap, right? Uh, if we emptied an
entire queue out because all of the
nodes are canceled in it. Now, we can go
ahead and remove that Q from our heap.
And as a result, even though all the
operations in the heap are log n, n is
going to be smaller. So, that is going
to give us a time complexity advantage
for future operations. But basically by
actively removing things from the heap,
it also means that uh we're incurring
extra time complexity whenever we do a
cancellation. So the first thing is that
we're going to be removing a node from a
queue, right? Because we have a heap of
Q's of order objects. And so we're
removing an order object from that Q. Uh
we know that removing arbitrary nodes
from Q's is actually an O of N time
complexity. However, there are
optimizations that we can make in order
to improve this. For example, instead of
just using a Q with a linked list
implementation, we can implement our Q
via a doubly linked list with a hashmap,
which I've covered plenty in prior
videos. And by doing so, uh, we can
basically use our hashmap in order to
get the location of the node and then
remove it in O of one time. So that does
save some time complexity there, but it
still doesn't stop the fact that if we
ultimately have to remove the
corresponding que from the heap because
you know there's no more order objects
in that queue, meaning all the orders at
that price point are no longer
available. Now we have to remove that Q
from the heap and that is going to be a
log and removal assuming that we know
the location of the Q in the heap, which
is only going to happen if we have a
hashmap pointing to it. So again, this
is, you know, getting very
algorithmically complex at this point.
The other option that we actually have
uh allows us to not remove anything from
the heap uh unless it's actually going
to be popped from the top of it. This is
because we could lazily mark orders as
canceled by basically just setting a
field in them called cancelled and then
as we run through our cues during our
our while loop as we check for orders to
potentially fill. Uh if we see that an
order is marked as canceled, we just go
ahead and skip over it. Um, so this does
have some uh time complexity advantages
in the sense that we'll never have to
remove anything from the middle of the
heap. But it also does mean that if
there's a lot of cancellations, we may
just constantly be popping nodes from
the heap. Uh, taking a good look at them
and saying, actually, you know what, we
no longer uh want to consider you
anymore now. We just have to move on.
So, we're going to add time complexity
there. And in addition uh by not
actively removing empty cues from our
heap uh we're also going to have more
nodes in the heap. And again like I said
before even though the time complexity
of a heap is always O of log N is going
to be larger because there may be some
empty Q's in there.
Okay let's go ahead and put this all
together. So I'm actually going to go
ahead and implement everything that I've
just spoken about so that I can
materialize it for you guys and it makes
a little bit more sense. And
additionally, one of the things that I
want to do is um kind of do the active
cancellation method, not the lazy one.
Uh so you guys can see how that would
work in reality. So let's go through the
fields of the order book itself and we
can go ahead and work out what we have.
So we have our min heap for the best ask
part of the order book. We've got our
max heap for the best bid part of the
order book. Uh we have a hashmap from
order ID to order and that's I'm going
to call order map. It's going to allow
us to cancel orders pretty easily. We
also have a volume map which like I said
before is keyed by um basically a price
and a side. And then we also have a Q
map which is basically saying find the
corresponding Q that's part of a heap uh
as keyed by price and side yet again.
And that's going to allow us to easily
remove Q's from a heap in log end time
as opposed to linear time. Okay. So
we've got our place order method. So the
first thing we're going to do is figure
out what the opposite side of the book
is. So, if I'm buying, the opposite book
would be sell. Uh, and if I'm selling,
the opposite side of the book would be
buying. I'm doing the same thing for the
same side of the book. And then I'm also
placing our new order that's going to be
placed in our order map. Okay. Now, this
is kind of the the crux of everything.
We're going through our while loop and
basically filling it as long as there's
volume in our order. We're saying while
there is order volume, while the
opposite book isn't empty, and while the
first order to be filled in the opposite
book, aka the one with the best price
for us, has volume, we're going to go
ahead and actually figure out the other
order, which is just going to be at the
top of the other heap. Uh, we're going
to figure out the trade price, which I
basically said is going to be the price
of the other order that is already in
the book. The volume is going to be the
minimum of volume between our order and
the one already in the book. And then we
can go ahead and print and basically say
um you know here's a trade that's
happening. And we're going to have to
adjust both our orders volume and the
other orders volume by subtracting the
amount of the trade volume. Then finally
the last piece of the puzzle is
basically saying if the other order no
longer has volume left, we can remove it
from our book. And we can do that by
calling the cancel method. Um I'll go
into the cancel method in a little bit
because uh we've extracted it away for
now. Um but it's effectively just going
to remove the other order from the limit
order book. And then finally, if we've
gone through our while loop, we filled
every single order that we can as part
of the one that was just placed and
there's still volume left to be filled,
you know, so I let's say I wanted 50
shares of Google and I was able to buy
45, but now there's five left. I'm going
to go ahead and put those five left into
the order book. And I'll go ahead and
show that helper method in a second.
Okay, so we've got add order to book
where I'm basically saying which half of
the book that I'm putting it in. And I'm
also giving myself the order node here.
So now all I'm going to do is say, okay,
if there's no price uh that uh basically
corresponds to what the order should be
going in, we have to create that price
Q. And once we've created that price Q
and it exists, we should go ahead and
put the order in the price queue and
then furthermore increment the actual
corresponding volume of the price and
side corresponding to the order. So easy
enough, fine. Add order to book, sure,
just a helper method. Um, and then now
we actually have cancel order because we
used this before. So let's go ahead and
do it again. All the cancel order is
basically saying is we look for the
order ID in our order map, which would
indicate that the node has yet to be
cancelled. Uh so it's probably somewhere
in the order book and it hasn't been
filled either. And basically now all
that we're going to do is go ahead and
say okay uh we're going to go in the
order map. Uh we are going to look at
our price Q that this node should be a
part of. We're going to remove the order
which we got from our hashmap. So this
is going to be an O of one time because
I'm assuming that price Q is a doubly
linked list. And then finally, we're
going to say if the price Q that this
order was now a part of is now empty, we
need to go ahead and remove that price Q
from the heap. This is going to be that
login removal. I keep writing N login,
but that is a typo. And then finally, we
can go ahead and remove the volume of
this order from the order map that's
corresponding to it. And also delete the
order from uh the order map as well. So
again, yeah, we're just subtracting the
volume, deleting the order from the
order map. Simple enough. We're
basically just undoing everything that
we did when adding an order. The last
piece of the puzzle is getting the
volume at a specific price where all
we're literally going to do is call
volume map uh because we already have
this, you know, kind of listed out for
ourselves, which is really great. So, we
return volume map with a given price on
the side and we'll get the corresponding
volume. And, you know, if it's not in
the hashmap already, we're going to
return zero. There's nothing in there.
Easy enough.
Okay, moving on. Let's go to extensions
to the problem. I know this is going for
a while and I really have to poop, but
whatever. Um, basically, let's imagine
that no longer do we have limit orders,
but now we have something called market
orders. Market orders are basically
saying, okay, we're no longer specifying
a specific price that we want to buy at,
but we're actually just specifying a
volume. And so, you're going to go ahead
and uh, you know, fill as many shares of
the volume as you can. And then, if
there are still shares remaining left
over, don't put any order in the order
book, just get rid of it. Uh, so this is
pretty simple. we would actually do
something similar to the limit order.
We're basically just going to continue
to run through the heaps as normal,
right? So, if I'm trying to buy and I
say, "Let me buy 20 shares. I don't care
what price they're at. I'm going to
start from the bottom of the sell order
book, aka the lowest price that people
are willing to sell at. And I'm just
going to keep filling those orders as
much as possible until I have gotten all
of my 20 shares." Okay. What is another
extension to the problem that I've seen?
I've also seen trigger orders. Trigger
orders are similar to limit orders, but
basically you set a price and then the
second that um the book basically
crosses that price, the second the
spread uh or there's a transaction that
is um basically beyond that price now
the trigger order is going to basically
place a given order uh as specified by
the trigger and trigger orders can even
trigger other trigger orders. So
basically all that happens is you're
running through your algorithm as
normal, but every single time an order
is a trade is executed, you can
basically have separate heaps uh that
correspond to basically the
lowest sell trigger order and the
highest buy trigger order. And then you
can basically check them that way. And
once a trigger order is triggered, you
can put it in a queue of trigger orders
to run through. Uh, and then you can
start executing all of the trigger
orders in a queue before you place any
new orders or accept any new orders to
be placed. Annoying, I know. Uh, if you
guys want me to go into more depth in
this in the comments, I'm happy to do
so, but I don't really think it's a main
part of the video here. All right, guys.
Well, well done. This was a lot. I know.
Um, but uh again, you know, if you're if
you're feeling uh particularly generous,
I'm feeling particularly accepting. So,
uh yeah. All right, guys. Well, I hope
you appreciated the video. Um, like I
said, this is a problem that, uh, I
don't really think there's that good of
like a posted solution online for this.
Plus, in addition, uh, it is something
that definitely has come up in
interviews that I've done in the past.
And so, uh, yeah, I'd recommend, um,
learning this one up, especially if
you're planning on applying to any
finance companies. But, uh, yeah, best
of luck, guys.